Good Morning Ladies and gentlemen.
It's an honor to be here.
Thank you for having
[inaudible] Hong Kong. Um, yeah,
I hope today through this session,
both parties can have a blast.
And then at anytime if you feel that
you want to voice out or ask questions,
please feel free. Okay. So, um,
when I first got the invitation
to come to Google Hong Kong,
I was thinking to myself, what the hell
am I going to do at Google? Seriously?
Cause
you guys are the people I go to when
I look at my stuff seriously. Um,
it could be through the search engine,
it could be through, um, through maps.
I like to travel a lot.
I just want to unpack pack and not just
a wander off somewhere into the world
and, and, and see the world.
So I'm always, you know,
navigating to maps and a lately
actually speaking of which, uh,
I've been trying to pick
up on Maura Japanese. So
I do this a lot now.
Everyday. Hey City Sun
[inaudible]
Stella.
I've been trying to pick
up on more Japanese.
So lately I've made a Google
translate my best friend.
Right.
So have you been for forcing
my, my smart phone to converse in
Japanese with me? Cause you know,
we only have 24 hours a day, so yeah. But,
but I must say,
yeah,
sometimes the translations
I still a bit funky,
but 80% of the time it
does the job very well.
So thank you for whoever out there that's,
that's making my life a lot,
a lot easier. All right. So yes,
I do visit you guys very,
very often every day. Um,
but I'm not here to talk about,
you know, what we can Google.
I think you guys out of everybody knows
best what we can search on the Internet.
But,
uh,
maybe today we could touch on some
other keywords where we cannot fully
understand through the Internet. Maybe
keywords like, um, like creativity.
I think, um, I think creativity for
me, it's, it's, it's the biggest thing.
Um, either it be through my music or
my food shows or movies or my business.
Because I think without creativity we
cannot really ensure our place in the
market, in the market, and eventually
you will be left behind in the world.
Um,
creativity comes in many
different forms and styles.
I guess it doesn't have to
be through through movies
or or that kind of artistry.
It could be through through
tennis, it could be through
agriculture, architecture,
woodworking or electron,
whatever it is. It may be.
It could be through
programming or engineering.
I think if Google was not
as creative when were,
you know, doing the algorithm this back
then, it would not be what it is today.
So a lot of people would say,
you know, yeah, I'm not the,
I'm not the creative type now we all are.
We just have to find that one edge.
We have to find, you know, what, how we
can synergize and capitalize on that,
on our own strength.
But it is getting harder and harder to
be creative I think in this world because
everyday we are,
we are flooded by so much
content in our phones. You know,
all the blogs that we look at,
all the comments, all the lights,
all the streamings, all
the films, everything.
But unknowingly,
unknowingly we are so almost two
inspired to a point where we are losing
ourselves because we are taking
it in everybody else's ideas,
their thoughts, their voices. Therefore,
if we are not creative enough,
we tend to what we call,
uh,
we would ride on other people's
ideas. Let's twist. That's tweak.
That's a in golden while
we would say [inaudible].
But when we get into a habit of that,
we forget about being original,
being really creative,
starting our own ideas.
And to me that is very,
very dangerous because if what you put
up is no different than the person next
to you,
if what you contribute to the company is
just the same as everybody else in the
room, let me tell you something.
Next year, you won't be here.
The company doesn't need you.
Eventually.
The market doesn't need you and the world.
They don't need you.
So constantly ask yourself how you can
contribute more than the person next to
you.
I've been in my industry for more than
22 years now and they can tell you,
I asked myself that
question every damn day,
every day for music, through
film, through my shows,
through my business. How
do I be more creative?
That is very,
very hard.
And maybe even in some fields
it's getting harder and harder.
Like in music I would say that it is
harder for me now to compose a very good
piece of music then it was 1520 years
ago because the time signatures or the
combinations of the notes are
simply being taken, taken up.
It is harder to write something original
in the now and have it not sound like
that.
It has been written by someone sometime
like some song back then because it,
it's,
it's been done.
But in our world that's what is happening
is because all of the ideas are being
voiced out and we are seeing it.
So if we don't voice out loud
enough, clear enough, soon enough,
we are actually behind.
So I urge you there,
you know at the first keyword that
I would want to touch on is actually
creativity. Does anybody
have any, anything to say?
Any other things that you
want to talk about? Uh,
another word I would say is a
key keyword for me is experience,
especially well experience in terms of,
um,
the verb experience,
not the noun experience,
especially for you lot where your work
requires you to sit behind a desk and a
computer the whole day,
maybe the whole year. Um,
but I would say that it is very important
too to get out there to the world and
really experience it because I think the
phone still only brings you halfway and
you must walk the other half.
You know,
nowadays when I'm chatting with a
lot of the younger generation kids,
what really happens a lot is a, and maybe
the topic would be along the line of,
uh, Oh man, I was in, um, I was,
I was in Finland last weekend. The Aurora
lights was there, they're beautiful.
And then the kid would say something
like, yeah, I know, I know.
I saw it on Youtube. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I thought that was really cool.
I saw it on Facebook.
Yeah. Okay. I'm sure.
I'm sure it's an opening. It's an idea.
It's a glimpse of what it really is.
But if that's how you see
things you don't know.
Yeah. Again, it's a great entrance
to the world, but it's halfway.
Please,
when the opportunity allows get off
your butt and walk the other half,
which may be even more important.
Okay. Experience the world.
Okay. The phone is awesome. You know
the net is awesome, but that is,
that is halfway halfway.
Is it too early for you guys?
Cause you guys look kind of stale.
Okay.
The James Bond movie. We could start with
a more, more Q and. A if anybody wants,
please jump in
and thinks that that is on our minds
is also giving back. Right, right.
What about creativity?
It's about experience.
A lot of that is because we're sort of
going through life to a screen and we're
not interacting much.
I'm here at Google. Uh,
we spent a lot of time thinking
about what we're doing for Hong Kong,
how we're supporting nonprofits, how worry
providing services for schools, train,
break breakdown.
What advice do you have for us?
And also for the broader millennial
crowd who was interested in,
in doing something for Hong Kong.
How'd it get started? How to,
how to think about that and what
approach to take. Thank you.
Thank you. I think, uh, I think keep doing
what you're doing really, but, uh, we, we,
we cannot lose the, what we're trying
to do is, is share, I think this, uh,
this in this era and of course
sharing comes in different forms also.
And that's what chef nick the brand is
trying to do is because I think even now
when you see a family's going up, got
the other dinners, they're actually just,
you know, they're, they're eating
through looking through there.
They're looking through
their phones the whole time.
Actually that's losing the true
essence of why we are eating together.
And that's what we're trying to
promote through the chef nick show is,
is the guy who gets [inaudible] fine.
Yeah. What is [inaudible] fun is to,
is to actually enjoy a meal together.
And that's why that's what cooking is,
has also taught me is, let me tell you,
I was in really,
really bad terminus with my parents
for the longest time I was in.
I was in boarding school ever since I
was 12 and then at the age of 14 I was
sent to Tokyo to, to, to
start training in, in music.
By 16 I started working and I
never really got a chance to,
to have a relationship with my parents
and we have been on bad terms for the
longest time until, until I started
cooking because when you cook,
it's the food. You don't eat
it alone, you want to share it,
you want to get some feedbacks and it
gave me a medium to to know how to talk to
my parents and say great
load of Lou Hall or
in the East and Gogo,
whatever you cook back then was really
cool and you want to teach me. It became,
now it's now it's a habit. You know,
does a food matter? Of course it does,
but what really matters
is how you find your,
your way to share.
And I think keep doing what you're doing.
But if you can think of the third party,
then I think that the whole
picture is much bigger.
Cool. Why don't you take a seat. Okay.
We'll chat a little bit. Get comfortable.
Um, it was very inspiring. Talk,
hearing you talk about creativity and,
and the journey where you just mentioned
how cooking brought you and your family
closer together. Okay. Um, so
a little bit on chef nick. Um,
it's now in its fifth season.
We're seeing a lot of traction
both online and offline,
but I want to kind of go turn
back the clock back to 2014 what,
besides what you just mentioned
about the parents thing,
but what was the thing that made
you transition from the singer,
the accurate setting a phone to, to chef
nick. And what was that transition like?
I didn't think I,
um,
I wasn't looking forward
transition really.
I thought I could do everything together.
I'm,
I'm still doing music. I'm
still doing films. It's, it's,
it's weird because people look at this
like it, like, like I'm moving from, um,
from woodworking to pharmacy.
It's not that far. I think what
I'm doing with food, with movies,
and also music and the business together,
I think as a whole,
it has perfect synergy.
I don't think that they're really
unrelated and that's how I do things.
If I cannot pull resources from somewhere
somehow to contribute into a new thing
I do,
then I really would reconsider
to either do it or not,
because to start fresh at, uh,
you know, at, at, at a later age,
later age is maybe at a disadvantage.
Um,
but first of all, I, I've found
food to be a true passion.
And then I also saw that it
would be the next biggest thing,
uh, after communication and, and tech. Um,
so I thought how I could, you
know, kind of rejuvenate the whole,
the whole entertainment business
of mine and make it a yeah.
And make it a long lasting one, I
guess. Was this interest in food?
Something that was always there,
that was always there, but, uh, I,
I thought to make it a bit more
bit more serious. And at the time,
I think mainland China was actually,
it was really lacking, uh, uh,
a decent food or lifestyle
show. Okay. Yeah.
So we started, uh, two Oh
14, right? Yeah. And um,
and it's,
we just finished the fifth season
this year that I've been watching.
Uh, thank you. Um, so on the food topic,
I'm sure you hear this a lot and then
even people who know me doing this have
asked this as well as that you've
never worked in the kitchen. You can,
you really cook.
Like obviously I heard stories and I
know that you put a lot of hard work and
dedication,
courage into,
into being who you are today
in achieving what you've done.
But not everybody has seen that.
So what goes through your mind when you
hear criticism like this and how do you
deal with is logically acceptable?
Because first of all,
we may think that because someone has
not been doing something for really long,
they can't be good at it.
Right? That's the logic.
It's okay. It's okay. But that's almost
like saying, let, let me put it this way,
that's almost like saying
we as a human race,
we've been using the landline
telephone for centuries.
Why don't we stick with it? That must be
the best way. So dump all your iPhones,
dump all your mobiles right now let's go
back to the landline because we've been
doing that for the longest time,
right?
That's like saying we as a human
race, we have been using the, uh,
we've been driving gasoline
automobiles for centuries.
So has Elon Musk on crazy
to start the hustler,
right? Why? Why are there so many
electronic cars out there now?
Because that must be the best way because
we've been doing it for the longest
time.
I think we are that narrow minded.
That really frightens me
because we are in a new era.
There are,
there are perks and different texts now
out there that allows us to pick up on
information much more rapidly than
it has been in a traditional kitchen.
I would say. Oh, I'm, I'm sorry.
But the way I've heard is, you know,
maybe the first apprentice cook with
would would be be peeling vegetables for
maybe a year or two.
But I have,
I have my ways or I am,
I have saved up enough money to be peeling
something much more in the first year.
Yeah. I mean like we hear
all these stories about like
chefs training in Japan,
like washing rice for like seven
years before they can play Sushi.
So is that the best and only way?
I don't think we have,
we can be that narrow minded in
thinking like that. Right, okay.
Of course there has been a lot of hard
work and time and effort put into it,
but yeah, I don't have
to get into those. Yeah.
But how do you stay focused
on doing what you need to do?
Do you have like a system,
do you have a way to do things or,
um, cause obviously it's a lot
of work. It's a lot of work.
There's a lot of learning involved.
Like do you, how do you stay organized?
How do you stay focused? That's
one thing I learned in the, in the,
in the kitchen is time management.
Because when you're just trying to
serve two dishes, it's easy for too,
it's easy for, for, it's okay
for eight years, not bad.
But when you're trying to do
eight dishes for a table of 10
and they have all the, they all have
to be hot. When you serve and liking,
you know, Chinese food,
it's not that easy.
And when you do one of the more
than one of my Michelin guidelines,
when you're searching for a 700,
they still have to be hot and you've got
eight minutes of serving time for a 700
fine dining. It's very
hard. But then you learn,
you know, gradually, eventually you
learn how to, how to, um, how to time.
You have to pace ourselves and
then your, your, your organization.
Like what I just demonstrated the, on
the, on, on, on, on my phone. You know,
I tried to squeeze in all these little
seconds and milliseconds in my life to,
to,
to gain that just that much more.
But I guess when there's a will,
there's a way, I don't know,
you're a time schedules,
but you figured that out for herself.
But there are these little gaps in life
where you can just squeeze in a bit more,
you know,
here and their knowledge and
then eventually that adds up.
That adds up.
Yeah.
I think it's amazing how you're able to
balance so many things and do everything
so well. And I'm a very
naturally, I'm up very
Bhagwat person. I'm a very,
I, I'm very curious about
everything, you know? I mean,
I, I look up stuff just to, just to
know, just to ask why, where, when,
how so and when I start something,
I don't like to stop until I actually
get somewhere, you know? That's the,
that's just the personality.
I've heard many stories as well.
Oh really?
How,
how kind of focus you are and how deep
down you drill in to everything that you
try to learn. And I think that's
something that's very admirable.
I can be a pain in the ass
in that aspect. Yeah. Um,
but like, like I said,
you're a man of many hats.
You're developing a
chef career on the side,
you're have music, you have
acting all that together. Um,
kind of bringing the conversation
back to where it started with music.
You're last Cantonese album was in 2005.
Really?
One second
closer. Yeah. Right.
And then your last mandarin album
was 10 years ago was 2009. Oh.
So
I know that, I know you haven't stopped
doing music, so you've done movies, songs,
he's written songs for your, for your
show. And over the past 12 months,
personally I've seen you kind
of do a little bit more, um,
started with a 2018 six hat,
that performance,
he launched three singles this year.
Uh,
and you were a guest judge on the voice.
Um,
and now just recently you
had the Rth k performance.
So there's this foreshadowing something.
Are we going to see more
music coming from you
really planned this? I think I'm just
going with the flow really sometimes,
but I think at different
times with different um,
inspirations or,
or sometimes I,
I feel that there are different
advantages for different fields.
You know how sometimes the
stock market, you know, it's,
it's doing better than the real estate.
Sometimes like music is doing better
than film and that's how I can kind of
weasel around and do my thing because
there's never one trend that's always at
the top.
Yeah,
that's actually true.
If you really look at the market,
something is always doing a bit better.
And if the trend is like that and
you can kind of catch the wave
man, you're on top because
like when we started the,
the chef nick show,
we are definitely the,
the biggest food show in China.
When we started in tool 14 by,
by the third season we were doing over
300 million RMB and now we're in the
third season. But if you
catch the wave, that's that,
that's a different thing.
That's a different thing. So
I think, you know, we, we are,
we're doing various stable in,
in chef nick.
So I think now I have the time to
kind of do more music to more music.
So does that mean we'll see
the album an album this year?
I don't know if I'm working
on a full album, but, um,
but I don't really think if that
really matters anymore in the,
in the new market. Right.
But, uh, yeah, I'm,
I'm hoping for, I'm actually
working on a concert, but there's,
I'm going to ask. And in Hong
Kong everybody is, do you know,
starting a concert as a,
they have nothing else to do
and still hard to buy tickets. So we need
a bigger stadium. That's what we need.
Yeah. Yeah. We need a bigger
platform. You see more creativity.
I can book my, My, My,
my stadium schedule cause I've
been dissing it the whole time.
Well, time to get creative and think
about something different. Right. Um,
back on the topic of jungle hosing,
I'm the voice.
A lot of people have
said that this season,
it was a lot better than previous
seasons, I think. So, um,
personally I think you being on it
injected kind of a different dynamic.
It was, um, it was
interesting to see how you,
how seriously you took
it. Um, again, stories,
I heard a story that maybe I want
you to share with everyone about the,
the drumming performance. So actually
I heard from Derek, all right, uh,
how hard you prepared for it and how,
how you kept on like
preparation for, for, for, for the,
uh, performance is a, is a, is a given.
But actually when you
talk about the voice,
what I would actually want to share is,
I don't know how many people has to wash
the, uh, the, the, the, the, the show.
But you know how I got totally
bashed when I started, you know,
hammering the onto the,
uh,
the button at first and the first two
episodes because there are actually these
two new perks they change to with
a game play this year that, uh,
to start off with, um, all
of the contested, there
are about 150 contestants,
you know,
put into one room and they are watching
a live feed of whatever is happening on
stage. That performance along
with the judge's comments and,
and how they would choose their team.
That's one thing.
The second thing is each judge would
have a six person quota, uh, to,
to, to, to choose into, you
know, assembling their team.
And if you do choose a seventh person,
that person would have to battle
out any of their chosen, you know,
the person from the, the,
the, the original team.
So thinking like that,
there are a few things
I tried doing is um,
the first episode if people who has seen
this seen the show would see me just
hearing the,
the,
the first two sentences and then I would
be smashing on to the button. And then,
you know,
the reporter is the viewers who would
say he doesn't know Jack about music,
you know,
go back to cooking.
How could you choose some round from,
from just listening for
the first two words?
What I found out was I am very aware that
for the past 10 years, like you said,
my last album was maybe 10 years
ago. I'm very aware that, you know,
a lot of the younger kids,
they don't see me as a singer.
They don't see me as a musician.
If I were to fight for
these contestants over with,
you know, with the other other judges,
I would have a very big disadvantage.
The only way I could plant some ideas
into the hundred and 50 contestants that
are watching the live feed is by
hammering onto that that button and solely
turning around because
therefore I have the floor,
I have the power of speech because
they didn't choose the person I did.
So actually I'm trying to voice out
and tell not the person on the stage,
but the 150 in the room,
what I have done or what my views on
music is so that they would feel more
comfortable joining my
team. But then, man, I got,
I got totally bashed by the media, by
everybody else. Yeah, I can stop this.
This thought stopped this guy,
right? He's, he's crazy or whatever.
And the best one thing I found that was
really helping me out strategically.
The second thing is, um,
people are also passionate.
Before I would choose a lot of contestants
because I was solely pressing onto
the button,
but what I was also doing is I found out
if you had to choose a seventh member
and if your whole team was equally
matched, there were all, you know,
six of them were equally as good.
It's very hard for a newcomer to
choose who they would like to battle.
But if you have two that are,
it's crudo say this,
but if you have to,
that is obviously a bit weaker.
It's easier for the
newcomer to choose from.
So you can always keep on upgrading your
team, if that makes sense to anybody.
But, but strategically, I think I've
done something to you in the show.
Yeah.
So it seems that you took a very
strategic approach on how you,
how you picked your team and how you yes.
But at the end,
I hope all of these elements would
bring a better show. Right? What,
so how long was the filming
of the entire process? It was,
the shooting days was 29 days.
Okay.
But the whole process with all the
rehearsal thing and all the training was
maybe three months.
So over that span,
like being on the voice and this is a
relatively new experience for you. Yeah.
What do you think was the biggest thing
that you learned or gained from that?
Um,
for me it was a great platform to get
back into music because it has the most
reach right now in, in, in terms of
a variety variety shows in China. So.
Okay. Yeah. Are you going back?
Let's see. I Dunno. I Dunno. Uh,
okay. Yeah. But at some stuff like that,
like, um, kind of music shows and stuff,
ours still something you'd
like to definitely more
involved in. Definitely. Okay.
Um, as I talked about the
beginning of the talk,
you're the first guest we're having
here at toxic Google in Hong Kong,
so I'd be remiss not to
bring the conversation back
at the tech a little bit.
Um, I heard that you're
very heavy youtube user. Um,
so let's start from there. So, no,
no, I, you told me in the room.
So,
um,
what's your view on kind of
technology and how we interact with,
with platforms like Youtube
and other social media and,
and how do you think that plays into
today's world and even your own life and
career? Well, definitely
for, for me, it's a,
it's a very important part of my life now.
I think, uh, for, for any of us really,
we've just got gotten into the habit of,
you know, learning a lot. Even like my,
my kids, they're always on youtube.
Seriously. I think the tech nowadays,
it has really enhanced the
speed of our learning curve.
Uh, we are picking up, you know,
the goods and bads through the
three in the Internet. Like,
like even through food,
like how tech has really changed
food immensely. Do the, the,
the past 10 years now they deliver
delivery system has allowed us to,
to, to, to choose, you know,
fresh goods from the Internet. Uh,
stuff like that. You're not a
very heavy user on social media,
not as right.
And I'm not a social media guy,
but, but, um, I, if there's a
destination I'm looking for,
then I would definitely, you
know, go, go, go on that.
Do you feel that social media nowadays
has kind of become something that's,
that more or less kind of consumes
people and it's become more of an a deck
addiction for some people and what
takes away from kind of the benefits of
technology,
but then I think it's a balance between,
you know,
for everything that we do here, if we go
too extreme, it's, it's always, you know,
kind of harmful. Okay. So we
just have to balance it up.
Is that why you're not on it or just don't
like it? I'm just not in the habit of,
you know, doing the that, that
maybe it's just just not me.
Right. Yeah. But it's, it's uh,
I think it's also a platform for you to
kind of share your views and sure what
you've done and, and something like that.
So, sure. Maybe something to consider. Oh,
of course.
Of course.
I'm sure
you opened up a youtube channel and shared
your cooking tips. People every year.
One here would be love to subscribe.
That's another thing right
now that's really, you know,
there, there's a bit of a
language barrier, you know,
I mean I have a lot of clips
but they're in Mandarin. Yeah.
So if I do put it on Youtube, then
I would have to kind of, you know,
we do the exact same thing,
but one may be an English or in
Cantonese with that really pisses me off.
Right.
I have to do three of the same thing.
I would have to kill three fish.
Yeah.
And if you only kill one face,
people will be commenting again on saying
there's already a cut there.
Yeah.
Okay. Been meaning to ask you
about a show that you did, uh,
called celebrity chef east versus West.
So you faced off against
our chef David Rockwell, um,
and it was a five episodes in the mini
series and spoiler alert, you won.
Why did you choose to go film in English
or, uh, what was that experience like? Um,
well, back to the part where, you know,
a lot of people has been doubting me for,
for the cooking part.
So all you could do really
is just to go the extent to,
to prove yourselves. Uh, I think that in,
I've been doing that in
every field really. Um,
that's why I put myself
through competitions,
especially when you do a, um,
a foreign show like from,
from Fox den is not a chef nick show that
if I can put myself through that kind
of platform,
then the haters will be haters.
But at least I've gone the extent,
you know,
I might even be going back
this year to do, to, to, to,
to be judging or even competing.
Um, I'm okay with competing.
But yeah, I think you just have to
find yourself to find, find ways to,
to prove yourself.
I have done many crazy
stuff just to prove myself,
but sometimes that's,
you know,
that's the extent you would have to do.
I've jumped off buildings,
I've jumped off the convention center
in Hong Kong to to do my move and this
story when people, people also thought
that because I'm the son of, you know,
two celebrities, maybe I don't take my
job seriously. And that's, you know,
that's why I've been putting myself
through all of this hardship and this pain
and buildings after buildings.
Because if that's not serious
enough for you, then then what is,
it may be silly to some people,
but then you go try it. Right?
Yeah.
I mean like I'm sure like in the room,
not everybody is familiar with,
with how you started and everything,
but definitely as someone who
grew up in that generation,
I was able to witness this. All
the, all the negative. Yeah.
It was the same generation.
Yeah.
For people who didn't,
who, who doesn't know.
The first four years of
my career was 99% booing.
Yeah.
I would not get any applause anywhere.
The minute I stepped on stage,
it was all booze and foul language
and profanities for years.
And it wasn't because of what you did,
it was because of your background
or you weren't sure. And uh,
it was really, really tough for four
years. Every time I walked off stage,
I would see my managers and my, my, my,
my team, they would be just, you know,
they would,
they would be all holding their fist and
just crying and I would be the only one
that could walk back to the
changing room and cool myself down.
But I would,
I would have to endure that
for every day for four years.
And you kept going because back
then we had so much, you know,
when so much promotion to do all the uh,
all the uh,
performances back then it was work after
work cause there was no internet yet.
So everything was live everyday was live.
Every time before I walked on the stage,
I would almost get paranoid about being
booed because it got to an extent where
I could not hear one word of
the song I was saying it could,
it was getting that nasty.
Then somewhere in year 2000,
it turned around.
What was the turning point? I
don't know man. We don't know.
Maybe
be there was some new kid to pick on them
or
maybe they just got tired
of, you know, the, all the,
all the hating or maybe they saw or
maybe there was enough buildings jumped.
But, but what you mean is you didn't jump
the convention in 2000 you? No, I didn't.
I jumped it in a two or three, somewhere,
somewhere like that with, with, uh,
Mr Jackie Chan. But yeah,
you know, when, when,
when there is that need, you just have to
find your way to excel. Maybe, you know,
there are some crazy things that
we gotta do. Thank you for that.
Any live questions? During the
first few years when things were,
did you ever doubt yourself?
And
I did. Uh, but maybe
for a very short time.
I never doubted myself in terms of music.
I never doubted myself in terms of
all the hard work I was putting in.
Um,
I believe in,
I think I'm a logical person and I think
anybody can accomplish anything if you
work hard enough.
Yeah.
Really. I don't think there
was a time where I think I,
I could've given up.
I would just,
I'm the person that does not give up,
you know,
naturally I just have that kind of
personality. And the second thing is
I, I can't give up because I
had to make a living, you know,
a lot of people would, would, would,
would imagine that because I came from
a family of two actors and actresses,
an actress that I don't take my, uh, my,
my job seriously,
but I've been self sustained
ever since my debut at the age of
20.
I been paying my sister's education.
So, you know, that's behind the store
behind the scenes stories. But, but I,
I could not afford to give
up my, my, my job back then.
So I took everything more seriously
than anybody would have ever thought
of a question online. Um, do you think,
so you've been in, like I said, 50 over
50 films. I didn't know that. Yeah,
I look that up.
Um,
what's your outlook on the genre?
I've gone champion.
Do you think there's a future?
What do you think that future looks like?
Back to the creativity thing.
I think we are Hong Kong right now is we,
we are really lacking this part.
I think we have been geniuses
in the stock, the stock market.
We were, we are, you know,
excellent in the real estate market,
but maybe that's the last generation
that past generations to get by in this
generation, we've got to be really
creative in, in, in our own fields.
Like in movies, if you're
talking about the movie industry,
I think we've all had our fair shares
of the Marvel DC franchises where we've
all seen our Superman's Batman, Batman's
or iron mans are a hoax. Our flashes are,
I wonder woman's are, I can go on
and on and we have all seen them.
The thing is,
don't we have 5,000 years
of history and culture,
but yet we are still
shooting the monkey king,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
Someone's seen [inaudible] now,
right?
So I urge any of you guys out there, if
you guys ever fantasize about, you know,
our own superheroes,
please jot down something,
write a paragraph or two,
send them to me or to whoever you know
that you think can make something happen.
Because we have to, if we don't, we're
going to be really, really behind really,
really far.
Sin Send in
your movie ideas to me.
I'll pass them along. Yeah.
X life question.
Good question. I want to ask is
can you share with us the failures,
one of the famous story or the moment
you dealt yourself is a good decision to
kick off these chef nick show
and then if that, uh, yes.
How you overcome like how you self
motivate yourself and then put back the
passion.
Thank you.
Thank you. Uh, failures.
Wow. Many failures. Really.
Um, but I think in, in in business,
I would say one of the more
obvious ones who are, um,
I invested in a company that does
data postproduction at the age of 22,
23. That was two oh three.
I started a post company,
post production company and
we would do computer graphics,
we would do color grading,
we would do editing, um,
dubbing for a lot of
commercials and films, uh,
stuff like that.
Right?
So when you're in that kind
of a hardware tech company,
you buy a lot of stuff.
You buy a lot of, um,
we call tell us Sienese or editors and,
and Mike's and this and that.
But back then we were at
the end of the analog trend
and all of a sudden
things changed.
They don't use tapes anymore.
They went from analog to digital,
but all my hardware,
they were a lot of a lot of money.
So all of those all of a sudden went
into the cat and that's, you know,
back to the well where I was just
seeing if you can't cash the trend,
that's a different story.
I didn't back then and I lost,
I lost a lot of money back then. You
know, I had to mortgage my mind, my,
my house and all that, but
that was on me, you know,
everything just changed.
So,
but do I still do at
that time it was hard,
but I still believed in the,
uh, the net worth that I,
that I had built all the connections
and the work we were doing.
And then at the end we were okay,
but there were a few years I was really,
really tough. But as long as you have
to, you have to stick with it. I mean,
a lot of stuff I do, they, it
doesn't reflect right away.
Most of the stuff doesn't
reflect right away.
The chef next show didn't
reflect right away,
but eventually,
eventually like,
like how everybody would dump me
through my, uh, in my culinary journey.
But then last month or
two months, just, just,
just now,
I think maybe a lot of people that had
also had the chef Nick Mcdonald Burger.
It was really good. Thank
you. Thank you. At that price,
I think we did a great job. You know,
actually you're right after this meeting,
I'm going into inventing into the central
kitchen to invent the two Oh 19 one
again.
And we sold within five
weeks just only in Hong Kong.
We sold over 2 million burgers and
there is only, let me remind you,
only 6.7 million population in Hong Kong.
So things like a five.
Thank you.
But then yes, it took
five years to, you know,
to kind of prove yourself just you had
really have to stick with it on the,
just a quick question also online on the
Mcdonald's collaborations, right. Um,
throughout the whole process,
how many burgers did you have to eat?
Man,
lot of burgers and there were there,
there are w w w I a lot of burgers.
We also tested a lot of fries, a lot
of the ice cream, a lot of drinks.
And Yeah, there were a lot of
other crazy stuff that we tested.
Was that creative process like working to,
to create a new menu item or to do
something that's never been done before?
Like the pork chop. Right. I was so good.
I'm so good.
It's best part of being creative.
I think. Uh, that's something that I,
I really enjoy is creating menus or
writing songs and making something my own.
And, and when they gave
me the, uh, the, the,
the homework to, to, to start up something
that has home gone the full name. Yeah.
Hong Kong from way it actually,
right.
I didn't know how to translate
that, that, that, you know,
tastes a space of Hong Kong. Right. Um,
I was thinking how I could relate the
taste of my childhood to a Mcdonald's
Burger and there are other ideas that
I'm still working on, on, on right now,
maybe later in the kitchen
today. Stuff like, um,
you know how Hong Kong people would
love their gotta you Donna Ray, right.
I think that it would probably work
with a Golly, you will owe power, right?
Because that's almost as you were saying,
but
solder finger one gutsy
Haunebu it. Right, exactly.
But then you know, there, there are, there
are ups and downs we have to, to, to,
to um,
overcome like me,
if we do work on a curry dish and then
the kids would be left out. Right.
So it's a long journey,
but I'd really love it.
These are some of the creative juices
that I have to get out and I can't wait to
see what you have in store. Thank
you. Thank you. Any other questions?
Thank you for coming. Thank you for
being so honest with everything you say.
I could just feel it that you're,
you're not scripted. Um, so thanks James.
Uh, with, uh, seems like you have
a lot of wisdom, but you know,
you're invested in a company
back in when you were 22,
even though it kind of went through
rough times. So through all these times,
do you look up to somebody if somebody's
your mentor and the has always been
since day one,
um,
or that has involved depending on which
part of the industry that you're in.
Good question.
Actually,
I don't have that person.
I've always sort of my mentor as logic.
I,
I've really not gone to anybody
about much of this kind of stuff.
Maybe I should write really, but, but
I just don't have that person in life.
You will have to you. Um,
so yes, in my company, yes.
That's actually interesting. I
don't have that person. Are you,
are you open to seeking mentorship?
Like seeking help?
Yeah.
What I'm saying,
like I do with department.
Like I know you help a lot of young
people. Um, but you're also like,
I don't present yourself. Right. So like
when, when you do come across it? Yeah,
yeah.
Same gender
you do come across like
difficult decisions and stuff.
Like do you just solely you're comfortable
relying on yourself and I was just
thinking that through.
That's something I'm actually really
interested in because I'm facing similar
kind of situations for my career.
I've always been able to,
I've always been able to gradually work
out the problems in my life. So yeah,
I've really not, you know, found
that person to, to, to go to.
And then because of the different
fields that I work on, you know,
sometimes it's music, sometimes it's
a, it's film, sometimes it's business,
sometimes it's kind of a bit tech.
So there's not really that one person
that I can talk to regarding all the, uh,
different fields.
Believe it or not, some of us actually
laid off as well. So we can generate,
thank you. Thank you. Some people actually
flew in everything. Thank you. Thank you.
Nice to know that.
What is sort of,
what are the messages or expectation
or an impact that you have to bring?
I Ron Carson
through music, through movies. Of course.
Mainly it's entertainment and music.
I could say I,
I hope it brings more,
uh,
I hope my music can also stimulate or
console you in your everyday day life.
But in terms of a deeper message,
we're trying to do that through the chef
next show because as like what I was
saying about, you know, we
don't share correctly or,
or how we are missing the essence
of eating together. Um, I,
I really, really learned a lot
through the, did the kitchen,
the time management stuff,
the uh, the sharing part.
It has changed my personal
personality immensely.
I was a really different person
before I started cooking.
And I think especially
in this day and age,
um,
we hope to promote a lot more
activities or,
or
wilderness wildlife activities or
stuff that you could do, you know,
apart from just looking at the phone
or the computer, I think that's a very,
very important part of life.
Uh, I got a question more
about, uh, your film career.
So I just wanted to know
moving force. So, first of all,
congratulations on the best actor award,
but it's moving forward for your future
film projects are going to be pursuing
more action driven movies like the story.
Are you going to go for more uh,
virtual or dramatic roles that
have been a further challenge?
Your acting abilities?
I don't really have a preference.
I think that I am.
Um,
sometimes you need a bit of luck
when you, when you, you know,
when you're giving a script,
the cast has got to be right.
The story has to be right.
The whole crew has to be right.
The timing has to be right. We always
say that in the movie and the street.
Each movie has its own journey.
Really.
All you could do is do our best
when it is handed to you. Um,
but I do think there, there is
one that I'm planning on, um,
in a few months it is action packed.
I do think Hong Kong has defined
its roots some way somehow.
And to me,
Hong Kong movie is about Hong Kong action.
It has never really been
about Hong Kong drama. So
it's going to be tough. But I think, yes,
I'm going to have to take down and fight
again and maybe jump off some buildings.
I think many of us are
on video. And that you started
the talk with your work.
So I was just wondering, reflecting
back on your life path, um,
what are some of the keywords
that define your character,
who you are today that made
you to be a successful life?
Successful career clusters
and wisdom with us. Thank you.
Keywords would be creativity.
Create keywords would be,
uh,
B tenacity. Keywords
would be synergy, actually
resourcefulness, but different
keywords come at different times.
Really it to,
if I was to be greedy,
I would say every word is a keyword.
Yeah.
Cool. Um, so before we wrap
up, just one question from uh,
somebody watching from the
states actually. Wow. So
what time is it over there?
It is late. So basically they said, um,
at our headquarters we have a
program called kitchen sink.
And there are chefs that come all
the time too to teach how to cook.
And if you're ever in the area,
would that be something you would be
just did it?
Speaking of which,
you know,
I think I'm tech wise right now I'm
having problems with working on the Vr
goggle. Like when you're teaching cooking,
the problem is the depth. You know,
you can't lean into the pot
and see what's in there.
If you guys crack that problem,
please tell me.
Okay.
Yeah. Oh we can, we can work together.
Yeah.
Cause I'm still the,
uh,
Asia Pacific marketing director for the
digital domain company right in, in La.
And we were still doing all the
post production for a Avengers for,
for all those series. So if you guys ever
come up with that kind of tech, yeah,
tell me please.
Awesome.
So that brings us to the end
of our talks that Google.
Thank you everybody for coming and
thank you nick, for taking your precious
share with us.